this is not a trans woman
it's a gay man I mean it's a very
recognizable gay man making fun of women
becoming a parody of women it's a form
of drag
what amazes me is why the trance
movement isn't saying hold on a minute
this person is the idea this person
represents your average trans M to F is
it is absurd no take for instance Dylan
Mulvaney advertising Bud Light the
reaction that both sides have had it's
insane you go this is a person who
identifies as a woman whatever you think
of them advertising a beer is it really
the big issue of the day have we not got
more important things to talk about yet
it's become this flash point for both
left and right yeah
I know I'm I'm I'm riveted by doing
Mulvaney for a frontal reasons and I was
actually riveted by him
uh many many months ago because
it's an interesting case I I I I this is
not a trans woman
this is a gay man I mean it's a very
recognizable gay man making fun of women
becoming a parody of women it's a form
of drag
a a kind of musical theater kind of drag
taken to the ultimate conclusion because
he he figured if he couldn't become
famous in the Book of Mormon or or in
other and like he really went on The
Price is Right I think at some point to
do the same you can see the same act
that he's doing as a man that he's doing
as a woman there's no difference between
him before and after transitional except
for the dress
and the marketing and his use of social
media namely Tick Tock he's not even
becoming a woman he's becoming a girl
now
this strikes me what amazes me is why
the trans movement isn't saying hold on
a minute this person is the idea this
person represents your average trans M
to F is it is absurd
in fact it's a sort of parody of what it
might be not just to be a woman but to
be some sort of absurd girly girl who
can't do math and can't walk can't run
and can't throw and he does this he does
this whole gay boy Act
day six six being a girl and today I'm
in nature
love you
oh did you see that I gotta get out of
here so I just I I just look at it and
I'm just this is kind of Staggering and
then of course
it takes off and he gets all this and
then all these dumbass
uh Lefty liberal PR advertising people
just so then he's the Superstar I wait
that's my weight is he really committed
to living his life as a woman or
committed to living his life as a girl
performing for money in front of
audiences I think the right word for him
is Minstrel
uh that it's he's performing as a
Minstrel
he's he's telling especially straight
women nothing to be afraid of here
and I can represent all the cool things
you like about gay men pretend to be a
woman and Vibe with you and be your best
gay friend basically that's who he is
he's being a best he's being the classic
best gay friend to a straight woman
that's the line that's why he's selling
all these Goods because straight women
love him
do they I mean I know a lot of straight
women that absolutely despise him that's
probably true but a lot don't a lot
think this is super funny and cool and
it's sweet and lovely and he's all about
love and is against hate and uh look I
did there is I mean I'm just I'm just
maybe I'm wrong in identifying that but
they wouldn't be doing this for no
reason and he is popular I think he's
just a really weird
and a very idiosyncratic eccentric event
I don't think it symbolizes anything
except maybe the crisis that we're in
that such a person can become so
prominent and be taken
seriously in a way in which I really I
really think there are plenty of people
who have transitioned from male to
female who would find his parody of
their experience kind of disgusting have
we not just here on the very core of
this difficulty though because
we talked earlier about accepting people
the way that they want to be and yet
here you are you have unilaterally made
the decision I haven't I'm just giving
you my impressions as a gay man if what
I see in that picture now now you
understand I'm playing absolutely I do
but if you were to go along and then if
she he would go along and actually do
the actual transition and but most trans
people don't have the transition no but
if they if he were to uh
changes
passport or change his ID from male to
female I think that would be a I don't
think he's done that to be honest with
you I don't know all the details of that
but I think that's TBD
um I've just seen things like I watched
Milo for example he was a another kind
of minstrel appealing to another kind of
audience
um and
you know it didn't end particularly well